there's tyler anderson's numbers for you
numbers are pretty good era's a little
on the high side
ball line towards center field reynolds
on his horse and he is there
tyrone taylor out number two
love that target being set up by perez
there as adamus draws the walk
to center reynolds is going to handle
all three put outs
after happening milwaukee nothing the
buckos coming to bat this is freddie
peralta's numbers on the season yeah
numbers for freddie
16th start he does have one complete
game
frazier pops it up toward left
taylor
kevin newman
there's a drive to left come on newman
toward the foul pole and
happy fourth of july for kevin newman
his third
on july the 4th
that's a great way to get things started
and the one flying the ointment of
freddy's stat sheet
the home runs he will
give up the long ball and the pirates
get started early with that
two out walk
here's the one two from peralta and he
strikes out defo to end the first inning
and a diving stop by defoe and on the
first and the pick on the other end by
evans
wow is that nice that was a little bit
past nice
wow
two great plays on the same play
cb buckner calling balls and strikes
this afternoon and manny pina draws the
walk
and this one lined in the right of base
hit so first and second now for
milwaukee here in the second inning
and this one hits robertson
he does get it down
and there's one
and there's two oh there you go double
play
pirates will take it one nothing
pittsburgh
harris hits this one to right and garcia
is there at the warning track
here's peralta
and gold strike three
let's shut out his last timeout
taylor to right in this one drops in for
a base hit
there's a swing
and a miss and anderson strikes out
adamus for the second out in the third
only hit for the pirates as well
newman looking to change that but he
takes the wall
here's the pitch to reynolds and he
called strike three and peralta ends the
third
here's the o2 to hira swinging a man
struck him out 90 right at the top of
the zone
and a strike three and a one two three
here's the 2-2
and this one lifted into the air tyrone
taylor underneath it in left field
there's the first out here in the fourth
inning
oh how about that
evans gets the call
oh dropped recovers throws in the dirt
and hera can't hang on and into third
goes evans
got him and a nice save over there from
here as he was being pulled off the base
obviously kept his foot there for the
outs
here's the 2-2
swing and a miss struck him out
and lifted to right should be another
1-2-3 inning
it is for tyler anderson fastball that
they can't hit
and the latter has taken place
another scoop by adamus
five complete the newman homer has stood
one nothing
oh another big cut didn't cut down on
his swings at all that is bad
brews have managed only two hits against
anderson so far
and make it three
garcia slices one into right
there it is hey good call
got him swinging six punch outs
and finally
just the second hit of the game for the
pirates and of course it's ben gamel
wilmer defoe for two
that's a fair ball
just inside third and he kicks off the
short fence
and that is tremendous break for the
pirates it will score a run a double by
defoe two nothing
[Applause]
again throwing him anything to hit
[Applause]
two games for him keep walking
[Applause]
here's the 3-2 and a big strikeout for
peralta
out number two
runners off on the 3-2 to jared oliva
wow
and off pena he thought it had gone back
to the backstop the bases are loaded
and the strikeout to end the inning
so peralta had to do a lot of work he
did give up a run but the brewers still
only trailed by two
line to right on is alabama a little
shoestring grab
charged with one error
and over 650 chances
pop-up how about this
tyler anderson an eight pitch inning
here is jake cousins coming in in relief
of freddie peralta up to six innings for
him three hits two earned runs given up
had five walks and seven strikeouts as
hiro makes the play for the first down
anderson really tame their bats here in
this game
and this one
lying to hira a leaping catch very nice
play over there at first base
bednar's numbers brought to you by
sheilys his numbers have been good all
year
lifted toward right oliva
nice quick inning
made it a two-nothing game
opposite field again long run and a nice
catch out there
by jace peterson
oh just into the ball game moments ago
that's a big time play right there
shading a little bit toward the line
with the left-hander up man defoe is
switch hitter batting left-hander
against bach burger
they got a good jump on it made a nice
play
evans with the stretch on the
tough hop and a little pop up the
shallow right and a diving try but off
the glove of arias
oh
brewer's flying all over the place
and the 1-2 pitch box burger with the
strikeout to end the eighth inning so
now the brewers go to work great catch
out there by peterson adamus will lead
things off in the ninth inning now you
see
richard rodriguez numbers brought to you
by sheilys
this one fairball
and adamus hustling into second base a
great start here in the ninth inning for
milwaukee
needing a win badly this bucko club
and a six-game losing streak
we're a few seconds from doing just that
and
a star-spangled victory on the fourth of
july raising the jolly roger